hi everyone it's Jerry let's have a look
at a game from the 1959 candidates
tournament on the wide end 16 year old
Bobby Fisher and he's up against the 22
year old Mikhail tall
opening wise opens Sicilian night orph
okay if you happen to be a teacher
listening in right now and you're
looking for a good game for your
students one that highlights this
thematic D5 Pawn Break In the Sicilian I
think this is one to consider sharing
what we're going to observe in this game
is a battle over the D5 Square
white essentially loses central control
and once this D5 break is in watch how
quickly the white position collapses
watch how quickly the game can collapse
when you lose central control
in this game we have Bishop C4 or move
six
more development for each side Bishops
on a more secure Square
Bishops out both Queens are out this is
already a time sensitive position
move 10.
Fisher castles
now when I share the graph at the end of
the video when the highlights
inaccuracies mistakes blunders castles
is considered an inaccuracy
this is only a 33 move game
move 10 what is considered best
is F5
two in other words increase the pressure
on E6
it's hit now three times how should
black react to this best move F5
well black can't defend it for a third
time there's only two on it can't add a
third Defender
but you could influence one of the
aggressors not the bishop
but the night
by developing
and we're going to get this Knight
Exchange in and the pressure is reduced
now we're down to two attackers and we
still have the two Defenders here
now with this ver with this variation
I'm highlighting you'll notice what
piece or what pawn
hasn't moved
this guy
the E6 Pawn has not moved has not
captured
this guy is still on C3 so to move the
pawn or capture while this guy is on C3
you're probably asking for a problem you
would really have to take
great care over that D5 square if you're
doing that
so
how else
can black respond to the F5 advance
well if you're capturing like this
probably not good for two reasons one
two
these squares have opened up for the
three miners
what might be tempting a lot of players
as black here is to play E5 this would
also not be a good idea and this
variation that I'm about to share with
you
I think does a really good job of
highlighting this fight
over the D5 Square it's one that black
will lose
let's see how
it goes back first
the night Pawn is launched to attack the
Knight who is observing D5
but you'll notice white has not yet
castled
and can consider moving in a night Pawn
himself
you could always go queenside castles
B4
this Knight doesn't even move
white continues to press gives up this
material the night is rocked back this
night is improved the queen is rocked
back and look at this position I would
say it's a very
small investment for white to get this
dominant position look at
the black pieces they're playing on rank
seven and eight how valuable is this
Knight on D5 how valuable are these two
white pawns positioned in Black's house
on the king's side nearby there's
already F6 which is crushing
black is moments away from getting
blasted off the board
this line right here
in this line right here white has won
the battle over the D5 Square
okay
in this game we have castles
B5 and F5 is played only now on this
move 11.
what's considered best in reply to B5 is
a three to secure the Knight you're
stopping the B4 advance
okay in this game
F5 is played
the other tempting move
if you're looking from the white side
here the other tempting move is this
Pawn advance
this isn't winning for white the E5
advance so don't be tempted by this
uh double attack against the knight in
The Rook The Rook is basically poison
if you're playing this as white
how is it poisoned exactly some line
like this
Queen takes Rook there's Bishop B7 and
Bishop to C5 Gonzo Queen
okay
in this game it's F5
now comes B4 the Knight is kicked to the
edge and only after it is kicked to the
edge only it only after it is not on the
C3 Square
does black make the commitment with the
E Pawn goes to E5
this guy can't get here
okay
Knight goes back
what do we do from here what's the game
plan continue to develop
white has already lost this fight over
the D5 Square
this guy's gonna watch from the edge
the eventual D5 Pawn break
okay we continue to develop
we also happen to be generating a threat
needs more support E4
Knights are connected
this move is staying out of The Bishop's
way watches over D5 also connects
Knights
in some cases the Knight on F6 can be
removed but
it can be replaced
and it's there once again watching over
D5
alright from here Bishop E3
Bishop C6 two things happening
a little pressure
on this night and a new square has
opened up for the queen
where she could increase the pressure on
these Center squares D5 and E4
okay in this game Bishop F2 is played
this is one of the last chances for
white to try and stay in the game
the best move here
is to advance the C pawn it likes C4 is
one of the best moves
what does this do it fights over the D5
Pawn break and also says if you take on
C3 on poisson
thank you my knight is back in business
okay another Point behind C4 is that
this C2 square is vacant for the bishop
in case black increases the pressure
with Queen B7 there's Bishop C2
okay in this game we have Bishop F2
getting out of the Rooks way this is
White's way to defend E4
I have a pop quiz for you in in this
game Queen B7 is played get this
increased pressure here but
what is
the best move
in reply to Queen A5
what's the plan here if black goes after
the Knight there's only one way
to approach this is why only one good
move here
Can you spot the move feel free to pause
the video
okay
white has to play A3
and if you take the Knight you have this
idea and The Rook is springing to life
this is how white would get the piece
back
so that resource is there for white to
secure the Knight A3
all right in this game it's Queen B7
more support needed over E4 but there
were two things going on with Queen B7
hit E4 and add another piece there to
get in D5 black has enough support for
it and here we go the position is
officially collapsing for white D5 break
is in all of this action in the center
is going on look at the quality of the
knights the white Knights On The Edge on
G3 they don't make a great impression
okay captures captures 94 Knight F4 as
soon as the D5 was in on what move 17
we're at move 19 right now black is the
first
side to establish a piece in the other
side's Camp Knight is on F4 and
there's other stuff going on we got this
pin against the Knight and this pressure
on G2
there's no save here for white what's
tried now is C4 too late
C4 in this case does not prevent D5 we
already have
d5n what is it doing it's opening up a
square to watch over the night
that's about it though
now comes G6
Simple Plan here this Knight's in a pin
how can I attack it further
trying to eliminate this Pawn
what are your choices in the game
we have Pawn takes Pawn any other
options
if you push we have this capture you can
get out the pin like that but you're out
of the pin but now this Pawn is gonzo
Bishop takes Knight takes
okay
that's not going to work out for white
trying to play this you're probably
asking for trouble as well
because soon you're gonna have to deal
with the Rook
coordinating on the king side
so what is tried is the capture
you could of course recapture towards
the center but this is tall
he just he's a forward thinker I could
play F5 I'm playing F5 and I'm not
afraid of your G Pawn
okay if the pawn captures the king hides
in this game the pawn goes to G7
King takes Pawn there's a check thrown
in no problem
Knight C5
everything's forcing
Knight takes Knight
Bishop takes Knight Bishop takes Bishop
Knight takes Bishop Queen C7
I on the night indirectly direct
defensive E5 right around the corner
Rook G8
and Rook G2 white gets out of that
trying to trade Queens
black says not so fast I have the safer
King
I'm still after G2
what's tried here is Rook to E2 and
Knight takes Rook follows there is no uh
there are no good moves here for white
if you're thinking about G3
that's going to get crushed after a
check and uh
F4 is in a fork this file will open up
big problems there as well
so in this game it's Rook E2 Knight
takes Rook
Bishop takes G2
Knight is hit
Knight takes A6 two different checks for
the queen
more accurate Queen A7 move if you're
going to B6
you know there's at least this move here
and your queen has to react to that so
you check
from A7 instead
King takes Bishop
Rook check what do you do king you go to
the corner you're getting hit with one
of these two checks to maintain two
in this game King H3
Queen G7 looking at made on H6
not much you could do about that what's
tried is Bishop to D1 one final move
Rook E6 and white resigns right around
the corner we have check
check checkmate ideas
for instance this check
check
and checkmate
this is as far as it goes though move 33
white resigns so look at this final
position
we have
off the charts active black major pieces
and
nearly every white piece is watching
from The Edge how did we get here
well
it dates all the way back to this fight
over the D5 Square it's one that white
lost
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below
I hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye
foreign foreign